this is James Lin in 1747 he had a
really noble idea he was going to take
all of these cures that had been bandied
around and actually test them so he
gathered a group of sailors who had
scurvy put them below deck on the HMS
Salisbury and treated them with six
different remedies and watched what
would happen to them for two of those
sailors he ordered them to drink a quart
of cider a day not bad two other sailors
drank sulfuric acid three times a day
that's a little worse two more took
spoonfuls of vinegar three times a day
the two worst off sailors were put under
a daily course of salt water didn't do
much then two lucky men were
administered massive doses of nutmeg and
if some of you may know I'm just
guessing here that if you take massive
doses of nutmeg you hallucinate for like
72 hours so the final two were given two
oranges and one lemon every day guess
who recovered yes of course the men who
were given the oranges and lemons
they showed visible good results right
from the get-go and a week later they
were so well that they were immediately
put back to work so what Lynn had just
conducted of course was the first
clinical trial he wrote about it in this
a treatise of the scurvy but Lynn
himself was never really accepted that
lemons or oranges were the single cure
for scurvy instead he subscribed to the
medical opinion at the time that scurvy
had multiple causes notably hard work
bad water and bad diet the treatise of
scurvy actually had very little impact
when it was published not a lot of
people read it and fewer followed it
meanwhile by the end of the 18th century
scurvy had become responsible for more
deaths at sea than storms shipwrecks
that and all other diseases combined
you